in The Fringe has always been subject to
complaints from puritanical groups you
know I mean when was it established
roughly 47 1947 something like that and
then by the time you get to the 60s
you're getting you know more sexualized
shows uh more controversial shows and I
think from that point onwards there were
always normally members of the Christian
right protesting even when I started
going to The Fringe uh back in the day
that must have been sort of like early
2000s and doing shows then I'd see the
odd group of Christian protesters with
Bible verses and things talking about
the degeneracy and all it is is that
those people are have been reincarnated
in a sense these are a new set of
Pharisees that aren't religious but they
have their own religion their own
quasi-religion which is the religion of
what I call critical social justice what
most people call the woke movement
they're the same